is it possible that ancient humans
actually did live to be several hundred
years old or even thousands and in some
cases tens of thousands of years of age
now before we just dismiss this as
nonsense or mistranslation of historical
text or even just symbolism of something
else let's just consider where we are
today in 2017
we've been cloning animals for more than
20 years in fact Dolly the sheep in 1996
was the first animal we ever cloned and
since then we've cloned at least 15
different species of animals whether it
be farm animals monkeys fish all kinds
of different animals and we're even now
cloning human organs on the backs of
mice and in in petri dishes
I mean we're even cloning human hearts
and now that people are living longer
than ever I mean where are we going to
be a few hundred years into the future
assuming we don't destroy ourselves by
then I mean think about how longer
lifespans will be three four or five
hundred years into the future
I mean think about that we have a bunch
of nerds and laboratories right now
growing organs and petri dishes and I
say nerds is a term of endearment by the
way so what's to say what's possible
what isn't I mean as of today if you
have a hundred thousand dollars you can
pay a company in South Korea to clone
your dog so when the Sumerian text which
lists all kinds of really interesting
information I mean somehow the Sumerians
knew of the planets in our solar system
and they knew that Mars was smaller than
Earth Jupiter bigger than Saturn and
Saturn bigger than Uranus and so on I
mean how did they know this thousands of
years before any telescope allegedly
ever existed yet they claimed that their
King gods live to be tens of thousands
of years old which of course many people
will dismiss as symbolism or nonsense or
whatever but let's not forget how many
different civilizations from across
multiple continents around the world all
say the same thing
ancient Chinese texts Indian Persian
Greek Sumerian texts from the Bible all
say the same thing that before the flood
we live longer than we do now I mean and
now it's slowly going back up again so
is it really out of the realm of
possibility now a lot of people will say
well wait a second if we were so
technologically advanced we would have
proof where there would be more evidence
of this laying around that we would find
now let me use the example and I've used
this in other videos of course which
that of the Titanic 105 years ago 50,000
tons of steel and iron a boat that was
more than 800 feet long sank to the
bottom of the ocean and now today it's
more than halfway gone and just a few
hundred more years will be completely
non-existent and I've also used the
example of cars and houses that say if
you leave a car outside unattended for
several decades it will rust itself
straight through same thing with a house
that if you leave it unattended will
collapse in on itself in a matter of
decades so when we're talking about a
length of time of tens of thousands of
years let's not forget that nothing
survives other than stone so any
evidence that would be looking for is
well it's gone now and not to mention if
the most advanced civilizations at in
ancient civilization lives on the
coastline as they do today well what
would happen with a 400 foot rise in sea
level I mean it's all gone right is it
possible that ancient humans were once
so advanced that they were able to
repair their DNA and grow new organs and
able to live to be 900 years old or a
thousand or even tens of thousands of
years old I mean we're at the point now
they say that in just a few years we'll
be cloning our first woolly mammoth
literally and they're even talking about
how long it'll be before we clone the
first human which I suspect has already
happened I mean think about it countries
like North Korea or China or even the
deep state intelligence agencies with
the United States I mean come on they've
probably already done it already it's
disturbing to think about but this is
the world we live in you think the
scientists somewhere haven't gone rogue
and tried that out it's time we start
entertaining new questions because
obviously following the last Cataclysm
that happened approximately eleven
thousand six hundred and thirteen
thousand years ago a dual event of
discusss and numerous videos that
obviously it would be a reset button for
everything we would lack any type of
evidence of it anyways so what are the
odds that you have numerous
civilizations across multiple continents
all saying the same thing
maybe there is some truth to it and
we're obviously heading in that
direction again we're living to be
longer than ever they say that the first
150 year old people are already alive
and driving around today I mean there's
even legends and stories that people
have lived to be 150 years old already
but they weren't able to verify it so of
course the Guinness Book of Records
never took it into consideration anyways
guys I want to make this video just to
get it out there and get people thinking
because you know something that I you
thing was just ridiculous or silly
symbolism I mean it was until just a few
months ago that I started actually
thinking about it you know maybe there's
some truth to this I mean history does
repeat itself right anyways guys I'll
leave it at that like and subscribe and
leave me a comment let me know what your
thoughts are but I'm Jimmy this is
bright insight I have many other videos
to come and a whole wide variety of
topics take care everybody